das sind wirklich spannende solarzellen
kanadische forscher haben sich bakterien
zu nutze gemacht die wiederum einen
farbstoff produzieren der sonnenlicht
absorbiert das tolle energie
diese zellen könnten auch in regionen
effizient arbeiten in denen die sonne
nicht so häufig scheint die revolution
der energieversorgung kriegs um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen das forschungsteam
aus kanada hat sich bakterien und zwar
escherichia coli e coli für sein
experiment zu nutze gemacht wir kennen
es weil es im menschlichen und
tierischen darm vorkommt und außerdem
auch der auslöser für durchfall und
darmentzündungen sein kann
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben e coli-bakterien
gentechnisch so verändert dass sie große
mengen von dem farbstoff lycopin
produzieren er sorgt in pflanzen dafür
dass licht effektiv eingefangen wird
wichtig für die zellen die photosynthese
durchführen der farbstoff ist
beispielsweise in tomaten und hagebutten
enthalten und verleiht ihnen ihre rote
farbe die gentechnisch veränderten
bakterien wurden dann von den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern mit titandioxid einem
halbleitenden material beschichtet und
auf ein glassubstrat aufgetragen fertig
war die neue form der solarzelle pro
quadratzentimeter wurde so tatsächlich
eine stromdichte von 0,68 6 milliarden
im kanadischen forschungsteam sei dass
die höchste stromdichte die je bei solch
biogenen solarzellen erreicht werden
konnte nämlich doppelt so viel wie
andere bislang entwickelte zudem seien
alle benötigten materialien nachhaltig
ungünstig herzustellen vorteilhaft an
dieser idee ist auch dass der farbstoff
nicht aus den bakterien extrahiert
werden muss sondern e.coli gleich mit
verbaut werden kann
laut der beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sei jedoch vor allem die effizienz
überzeugen denn egal ob die sonne viel
oder wenig scheint biogene solarzellen
arbeiten bei weniger licht genauso
effizient wie bei viel ich dazu der
projektleiter wie kann man dies ja darf
damit haben wir eine grundlage
geschaffen um solarenergie
wirtschaftlicher kostengünstiger und
einfacher zu machen das problem die
bakterien sterben ab deshalb sollen
langfristig solarzellen entwickelt
werden bei denen die bakterien nicht
absterben sondern immer weiter lycopin
produzieren das prinzip solcher
solarzellen bei denen organische stoffe
sonne in energie umwandeln ist
allerdings nicht komplett neu schon 2016
hat einen us forschungsteam einen ersten
prototypen eines bio solar panels gebaut
konkret wurden hier neue bio solarzellen
zu einem solarpanel vereint es basiert
auf zulage bakterien die zur
photosynthese fähig sind und innerhalb
des experiments auch überleben dies
gelang indem man eine karbon anode
eingesetzt hatte die in die
bakterienhaltige flüssigkeit getaucht
werden musste so wurde die luftzufuhr
der bakterien gewährleistet und die
zelle konnte autark arbeiten der strom
wurde hier sowohl aus der
atmungsaktivität als auch aus der
photosynthese der bakterien gewonnen
eine permanente leistung von 5,59
mikrowatt konnte so unter lichteinfluss
erzeugt werden auch wenn das erstmal
nach nicht viel klingt ließe sich damit
immerhin eine armbanduhr antreibend okay
aber eingesetzt werden könnten solche
bier solarzellen vor allem in entlegenen
regionen wo regelmäßig batteriewechsel
nur schwer durchzuführen sind und auch
der anschluss an das stromnetz nicht
gegeben ist doch auch wenn die
beteiligten forschungsteams optimistisch
sind die stoffwechselvorgänge von
bakterien sind noch nicht ausreichend
erforscht und aufgrund ihrer doch eher
niedrigen energie effizient für
praktische anwendungen bislang noch
nicht wirklich weit genug entwickelt um
sie in masse zu produzieren doch
prinzipiell ist die weiterentwicklung
solcher ideen enorm wichtig um die
nachhaltigkeit der stromgewinnung zu
maximieren und weil die technik eben
noch am anfang ist sind schon in naher
zukunft größere sprünge hinsichtlich der
produzierten strommenge zu erwarten
bedeutende entwicklung sind also zu
erwarten
die bedeutendsten entwicklung und
entdeckung des letzten jahres das
wissenschaftsteam 2018 gibt zwar doktor
watson mit dabei ganz vieles 1 julia war
also anklicken anschauen und dr watson
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran